welcome to M coding today we're hitting
a common problem with some recursive
algorithms causing them to fail on even
moderately sized inputs
let's say you have to Traverse a tree in
some way
the tree is made up of nodes that
contain some data and zero or more child
nodes
let's take a dead simple recursive task
just printing out the nodes
here's the whole implementation yes it's
that simple
we print out the current node then Loop
over the children recursing on each
child
the order we're going in here is called
a pre-order traversal by the way
and it works
when we give it this small example it
prints out all the nodes in the expected
order
first the root then child zero the three
children of child zero which are zero
zero zero one and zero two
and then child one of the root
so great all your tests pass it's simple
and readable you ship it to production
and the second a client touches it Wham
Obama it instantly breaks
surely they must have passed a ginormous
unsightly pathological Tree in order to
break the Perfection and elegance that
is every line of code beget of your
golden fingertips
uh nope they passed a linked list with a
thousand nodes in it
what went wrong is you hit the recursion
limit which is a mere 1000 in Python by
default
that's why the crash happens near a
thousand children
you can increase the recursion limit
using sys dot set recursion limit but
that doesn't really solve the problem
the recursion limit is there to fail
early in the case when you accidentally
cause an infinite recursion so you can
crash the program instead of running out
of memory and crashing your whole
computer
increasing the limit a lot would defeat
the purpose of having the limit
but only increasing it a little bit is
just asking for the client to hand you a
2000 node list in the future
so what do we do we use this handy trick
the idea is to convert your recursive
call stack into a literal call stack
making the entire function iterative
thereby completely bypassing any
recursion limit problems
we'll use a list as the data structure
for our stack append is pushing onto the
stack and pop is popping off the stack
we'll use a while stack to keep going as
long as our stack is not empty
then we indent this
and replace any recursive calls like
this one with pushing onto the stack
running our linked list example again we
see now it fully prints all the children
down to child 999.
but if we take a look at our first
smaller example we'll see that we've
actually changed the order that nodes
are printing in
before we had the root then child zero
then zero zero zero one and zero two
finishing with child one last
and the reason for that is because a
stack is a last in first out data
structure
the fix for this is that in our
implementation whenever we want to make
multiple recursive calls we actually
need to put them on the stack in reverse
order so they go in the intended order
when we pop them off the stack
so we just Loop over each node's
children in reverse order
then we're back to the same output as
before
we now have an equivalent function to
the original recursive implementation
that prints out our nodes and that works
no matter how deep a tree you pass it
but you may be wondering what if I had a
more complex recursive function that
doesn't just have a single node
parameter like this one
let's say I wanted to add a max depth to
my print
in the recursive case
that means checking if we've hit the max
depth and not recursing if we have
otherwise we do recurse and pass each
child one less max depth
to make the iterative version we do the
same trick as before but instead of just
putting the current node on the stack
we'll put a tuple of whatever arguments
we were going to pass to the recursive
call
we start by making a stack with the
initial arguments to the function
then we do a while stack pop off an
Element from the stack and unpack the
variables
popping the Tuple off the stack and
assigning to these variables restores
all of them to a state just like we
would have had if we had made a
recursive call
once again we indent
an early return in the recursive
implementation just means that we don't
want to do any more work in this
iteration
so in the stack version that just
becomes a continue which will Skip and
process the next item on the stack then
we replace recursive calls with just
pushing onto the stack any arguments
that we were going to pass to the
recursive call
and as before we need to put those
things on the stack in the reverse order
and now our Max step parameter is
working
the max depth of zero just means
printing the root if we have a depth of
1 then we'll use the root and its
children but we don't recurse to their
children
and a max depth of two or higher for
this tree we'll print the entire thing
so that's the trick it's just an easy
way to convert any recursive function
into an iterative one
but I did want to finish by just
pointing out one other issue with this
code
both the recursive and iterative
solutions shown so far still suffer from
high coupling
namely this function is actually doing
two things
number one it's iterating over the tree
of nodes and number two it's also
operating on the data in this case
printing out the nodes
if we wanted to do something else
besides just print the node we may end
up copy pasting this entire block of
code only to change one line
as you can imagine copy pasting huge
blocks of code just to change one line
is discouraged
instead let's decouple these things by
pulling out the part that does the
iteration and making it a generator
instead of actually doing anything with
a node let's just yield the node so that
someone else can do something with it
change the name of course
then we can Implement our printing
function just by iterating over the
nodes and printing
now neither the printing code nor the
iteration code needs to know anything
about each other meaning they're
completely decoupled allowing you to
plug in a different operation or a
different order of iteration without
rewriting or duplicating code
as far as functionality goes of course
it's the same as it was before but
especially in larger projects this is
going to make your code much more
testable and maintainable for the future
so just keep that in mind
anyway I hope you enjoyed the trick and
this video if you did don't forget to
subscribe and if you especially like the
video please consider becoming a patron
on patreon
so thank you so much and I'll see you
next time